It's impossible to imagine the long
awaited sequel to blade runner without
some version of the iconic music that
Vangelis composed for the original.
That's because the blade runner score is
more than a score.
It's an indispensable element of the
movie.
I mean,
you could make that argument about
almost all film music of movie minus
it's music.
It's not the same movie and,
and that's true too.
If you were to swap one kind of music,
nothing
in the video I did on Howard shores,
incredible light motifs in the Lord of
the rings.
I tried to show how the score helped
guide and elevate the emotional beats of
the story.
It's great work from a great composer
and hugely influential on the trilogy.
I think blade runner's music is
different.
It plays a different role.
The score isn't laid on top of the
visuals.
It's not a guide or an addition.
The music is sort of baked into the DNA
of the movie itself.
All the audio that you hear including
score,
sound,
design,
dialog,
it's tightly integrated.
Each blurs into the others.
Creation is really what separates blade
runner from other science fiction films.
After all,
electronic music had been a staple of
science fiction cinema for three
decades.
By then going all the way back to
Bernard Herman's use of the therapy in
the day the earth stood still herman,
another revolutionary composers like
Lewis and Bebe Barron used winding,
bending,
sputtering,
electronic sounds to evoke aliens and
alien planets.
Renner is somewhere in the middle
between the a melodic soundscapes of
forbidden planet and the grand symphonic
themes of something like star wars and
they gave us is pulling from that same
toolbox of electronic sounds,
but these noises are put to use for a
more musical purpose in order to achieve
that dream like quality that the film
has.
The audience shouldn't be able to
identify where the music ends and the
World
Ms Dot lyrics that infused this scene or
a good example of what I'm talking
about.
They sound a little bit like wind
chimes.
Something that could very well be in the
space and match pretty well with the
dancing.
The light on the walls and you have the
sound is so layered with faint computery
noises that it could also be a machine
somewhere in the room.
It also serves as a kind of atmosphere
at bed from which the clearly
nondiabetic not in the world.
Strings rise as Rachel enter
like even the dialogue has a lot of
reverb giving it the same dreamy quality
as the score and the sound effects.
Becker,
of course,
reverberation is absolutely everywhere
in blade runner.
You could even say that.
It's the manipulation of reverb that
gives blade runner it's distinct feeling
and the Vandellas is such a virtuoso at
wielding it.
The digital reverb that you hear in this
movie was something relatively new to
music at the time.
The world's first digital reverberation
machine,
the emt to 50,
was released only six years before blade
runner premiered in 1982.
We all have a natural sense of river.
We hear it when we're in big spaces,
how our voice reverberates and decays
across the room.
Digital reverb uses algorithms to extend
that decay even more.
The lexicon two to four,
which is what Vangelis used for blade
runner,
could extend the up to 70 seconds,
allowing you to make spacey a theorial.
Sounds like this.
The emphasis on reverb accomplishes a
few things.
As I say,
Andrew Stiller noted heavy river because
it implies a huge enclosed hard surface
space,
creates a mood of mystery and paranoia,
and also it gives everything a feeling
of distance as if the audio is coming
from far away,
like in a dream.
Finally,
reverberation blends things together,
and this is one of the crucial ways main
Gellis fold separate audio sources into
one oral master track because that is
the goal here.
Every scene is composed to create this
cohesive acoustic environment.
Sometimes the emphasis is on dialogue or
sound effects.
Other Times it's on the nostalgic music
that calls back to classic film,
except that Solo Saxophone was never
actually used in classic film noir,
which is a whole nother video,
but anyway,
most of these scenes were interpreted by
Ben Jealous on the spot.
The way he composed the music for blade
runner,
it was by watching the freshly edited
scenes on a screen in his studio and
playing whatever they evoked in him at
the time it used primarily the Yamaha
cs,
csad and analog synthesizer featured so
prominently in blade runner that bank
ellis has his own section in the CSAD
wikipedia page.
Even today,
the CSAD is prized among audio files.
It seems like anybody who ever writes
about it describes it as a living,
breathing thing that's partly down to
the fact that the keys were pressure
sensitive,
so the sound that it produced as a
marvelous acoustic quality in a way,
it's the perfect instrument for blade
runner,
a machine with the ability to match the
emotional weight of the real thing
in in one in one goal.
You can have from that to that to that
which is which different,
again,
as much as possible,
Vangelis used his spontaneous first take
compositions and the result is a deeply
personal reaction to the images.
A second vision that fuses with the
director's own is the great composer Ed
Guard before him attempted to bring to
life the complete sound profile of the
city,
interpreted through the genres of blade
runner.
Anybody who's lived in a large
metropolis knows that sound is a
constant feature there.
At night you might hear a siren or a
scream somewhere in the distance.
We may not have wheezing or sputtering
machines,
but these days we sure have a lot of
beeping ones vein Bella strings,
all these disparate noises together with
musical themes that are stunning and
appropriate.
When the music swirls,
it says,
if it's coming from within the
characters themselves,
like an internal cry or a release,
jelly evangelists isn't coming back.
For Blade runner,
20,
49,
his job is going to Johan Johansson,
a great composer who's worked with
director Denise Villeneuve three times
before.
I don't envy him.
I mean everybody is going to be waiting
for him to play someone else's iconic
music.
If I were him,
I'd resist the urge to Mimic Vangelis
completely.
As much as I'd like to hear every
classic note.
Again,
the sql deserves music as personal and
human as its original.
I'm excited to hear Johan Johansson is
interpretation of a world that so many
of us are so eager to return to
everybody.
Thank you so much for watching.
This episode was brought to you by the
great courses plus the great courses
plus is an on demand video learning
service,
which basically means that it's got
around 7,000
online video lecture series from some
Great Ivy League professors and other
professors about all kinds of subjects,
math,
history,
our galaxy,
etc.
One that I think you should really check
out is called music in the brain by
professor patel,
which explores in depth the neurological
relationship to music over 18 awesome
episodes.
If yOu go to the great courses
plus.com/nerd
writer to the first link in the
description,
you can get a thIrty day free trial and
after that annual memberships are 1490
$9 a month and monthly memberships are
1999 a month.
Thanks guys.
I'll see you all next time.